our society routinely makes decisions
without consulting a quarter of the
population we're making choices about
land use energy production and natural
resources without the ideas and
experiences of the full community the
car an inanimate object has more say
over public policy than this group of
citizens can you guess which group I'm
talking about its children I work in
urban design and not surprisingly most
cities are designed by adults urban
planners architects developers
politicians and occasionally a few loud
citizens rarely do you consider the
voices of a group of four-year-olds
barely tall enough to reach the podium
at City Council Chambers but today I
want to ask you this what would happen
if we asked children to design our
cities back in 2009 I was introduced to
a small group of people who wanted to
start a child-friendly city initiative
in Boulder Colorado I come from a family
of civil rights advocates and I had
spent my career until that point working
with low-income children and families
but I had never heard of a
child-friendly city initiative before so
I figured its purpose would be to
address some of the frustrations I had
encountered as the parent of a young
child perhaps we would advocate for more
changing tables and restaurants or
create indoor play spaces for those cold
and rainy days in other words makes a
city more hospitable to children and
families it was mental after I committed
to this project that I realized I had it
all wrong we wouldn't be designing
better cities for children children
would be designing better cities for
themselves and for the rest of us too
now I bet you're skeptical about this
idea and honestly I was too I mean there
must be a reason the voting age is 18
how could children possibly understand
complex ideas such as the affordable
housing crisis or how to develop a
transportation master plan and even if
they had ideas
wouldn't they be childish or
unreasonable do our cities really need a
park made out of candy or a bridge with
water cannons that fire water onto
unsuspecting kayakers below while these
concerns sound legitimate I realized
that not including children and city
planning was a bigger design problem
after all shouldn't we include end users
in the design process if we're building
a park to be largely used by kids then
kids just have a say in the park's
design so with all of this in mind we
formed a program called growing up
Boulder and my job is to work with
children ages 0 through 18 to come up
with innovative city design solutions
how do we do this you might ask let me
give you a real example in 2012 the city
of Boulder decided to redesign a large
downtown park known as the civic area
the space is bounded by a farmers market
on one end
Boulder Public Library on the other end
and by Boulder Creek which runs through
the middle the space needed a new design
to better handle the creeks inevitable
flash floods restore a sense of safety
to the area and support an expanded
farmers market so from 2012 through 2014
we engaged more than 200 young people in
the process ranging from preschool
through high school students now how do
we do this let me explain first we
visited children in their classrooms and
presented the project what it was
why their ideas mattered and what would
happen with their recommendations before
we could influence them we asked
children to record their ideas based on
their own lived experiences then we
asked children to go on a field trip
with us to document what they liked and
didn't like about the space using
photography through green picture frames
students highlighted what they liked
about the space such as college students
tubing down the creek then they flipped
those frames over and use the red side
to highlight things they didn't like
such as trash our sixth-grade students
studied the Civic area by researching
sites with similar challenges from
around the world then we invited the
kids to combine their original ideas
with their new inspirations to
synthesize solutions to improve the
space each class invited adult planners
City Council and community members into
the classroom to share and discuss their
recommendations Boulder senior urban
planner stepped over blocks and stuffed
animals to explore preschool students
full size classroom recreation of the
Civic area adult planners marveled at
the students ideas as they shared a park
constructed out of a jelly bracelet it
was supposed to be an ice skating rink
and then public art constructed from
animal shaped plastic beads and while
this may seem ridiculous it isn't so
different from the models that
architects create now fast-forward for
years and I am pleased to report that
many of the children's ideas are being
implemented in the Civic area for
example there will be improved access to
Boulder Creek so kids can place safely
in the water lighting and previously
dark under passes so high school
students can walk home safely after
school at night and separated biking and
walking paths so speeding bikers won't
hit young people as they stroll by the
creek
my daughter and I even skated on a new
child requested ice skating rink last
winter so where all of the kids ideas
implemented at the Civic area of course
not democracy is a messy process but
just as a reasonable and well-informed
adult does not expect all of her ideas
to be utilized neither does a
nine-year-old we've now been using this
process for eight years and along the
way we found some incredible benefits to
designing cities with children
first of all kids think differently from
adults and that's a good thing
adults think about constraints how much
time will a project take how much money
will it cost and how dangerous will it
be in other words are we going to get
sued it's not that these constraints
aren't real
but if we kill off ideas from the
beginning it limits our creativity and
dampens the design process kids on the
other hand think about possibilities for
kids the sky is the limit
literally when we worked with middle
school students to design teen friendly
parks they drew pictures of skydiving
hang gliding and jumping from
trampolines into giant foam pits some of
this sounds far-fetched but the
commonalities among the activities
revealed an important story our
adolescents wanted thrill seeking
opportunities which makes perfect sense
given their developmental stage in life
so our task as connectors between
inspiration and reality was to point
them towards activities and equipment
that actually could be installed in a
park this is exactly what parks in
Australia have done with their extensive
zip lines and their 30 foot tall
climbing towers when kids dream up a
space they almost always include fun
play and movement in their designs
now this is not what adults prioritize
but research shows that fun play and
movement are exactly what adults need to
stay healthy - who wouldn't enjoy a tree
house containing a little lending
library and comfortable beanbag chairs
for reading or what about a public art
display that sprays paint onto a canvas
each time you walk up the steps in
addition to fun and play children value
beauty in their designs
when tasked with designing dense
affordable housing kids rejected the
blocks of identical beige condominiums
so many developers favor and instead put
bright colors on everything from housing
to play equipment they placed flowers
between biking and walking paths and
place benches along the creek so kids
could hang out with their friends and
enjoy the tranquility of the water which
leads me to nature children have a
biological need to connect with nature
and this shows up in their designs they
want nature right in their backyards not
four blocks away so they design
communities that incorporate water fruit
trees flowers and animals into their
common spaces on site for better or
worse this is logical because
five-year-olds today are rarely allowed
to walk four blocks to access a park by
themselves and nature and one's
immediate environment benefits everyone
since it has been shown to have
restorative effects for all ages it may
come as a surprise but we even take into
consideration the desires of our
littlest citizens babies and toddlers
from toddlers we learn that the joy of
walking comes from what you discover
along the way when they evaluated the
walkability of boulders 19th Street
Carter toddlers spend long stretches
exploring leaves in the ditch and
sparkles in the sidewalk they reminded
us to slow down and design a path
where the journey is as important as the
destination in addition to trees and
plants kids almost always include
animals in their designs insects birds
and small mammals figure prominently
into children's pictures whether it's
because they're closer to the ground and
can see the grasshoppers better than we
can or simply because they have a
greater sense of empathy for other
beings children almost always include
non-human species in their ideal worlds
across the board children are inclusive
in their city planning they designed for
everyone from their grandmother in a
wheelchair to the homeless woman they
see sleeping in the park children
designed for living creatures not for
cars egos or corporations the last and
perhaps most compelling discovery we
made is that a city friendly to children
is a city friendly to all bogota
colombia mayor and rico peñalosa
observed that children are a kind of
indicator species if we can build a
successful city for children we will
have a successful city for all people
think about it kids can't just hop in a
car and drive to the store and most kids
can't afford an expensive lunch at a
nearby cafe so if we build cities that
take into consideration their needs for
alternative forms of transportation and
for cheaper food venues we meet the
needs of many other populations too the
more frequent and more affordable bus
service so desired by our youth also
supports the elderly who wish to live
independently after they can no longer
drive cars teens recommendations for
smooth protected walking and
skateboarding paths also support the
person in a wheelchair who wishes to go
smoothly down the path or the parent
pushing a new stroller so to me all of
this has revealed something important an
important blind spot if we aren't
including children in our planning who
else aren't we including are we
listening to people who've come
immigrants the elderly and people with
disabilities or with reduced incomes
what innovative design solutions are we
overlooking because we aren t Rijn the
voices of the full community we can't
possibly know the needs or wants of
other people without asking that goes
for kids and for everyone else so adults
let's stop thinking of our children as
future citizens and instead start
valuing them for the citizens they are
today because our children are designing
the cities that will make us happier and
healthier cities filled with nature play
movement social connection and beauty
children are designing the cities we all
want to live in thank you
[Applause]